bitcoiners love to say bitcoin fixes
this and we're watching a situation play
out in china right now where quite
literally bitcoin does fix this now what
we've seen is that depositors at a
number of banks they put their money
into the bank and they said i'll come
get it later but those withdrawals they
got frozen starting in april now all of
a sudden there has been a drastic
increase in concern among all the
depositors and so they've gone to the
streets and they're demanding that the
banks give them their money back but
it's not just any sort of protest we're
watching an uprising starting to happen
and that is not something that we're
used to seeing in china as brad mills
pointed out here the social credit score
system of control is breaking down in
china the need for bitcoin is growing
stronger globally every single day and
volatility is up globally as well and
now there's video servicing of the
protests and it's not exactly a walk in
the park more and more people are
showing up in the streets and they're
demanding give me my money back as we
know china is a really big place this is
all occurring in the hinan province but
over time the question is will it spread
to other parts of this large country
with over a billion citizens now we've
got a number of quotes from people on
the ground talking about how this is
changing the way they perceive the banks
and their government the first from an
anonymous protester said i did not
expect them to be so violent and
shameless this time there was no
communication no warning before they
brutally dispersed us
next up is why would government
employees beat us up we're only ordinary
people asking for our deposits back we
did nothing wrong
then
being unemployed all i can live on is my
past savings but i can't even do that
now how am i supposed to support my
family and lastly the incident
completely overturned my perception of
the government i lived all my life
placing so much faith in the government
after today i'll never trust it again
now of course we have people in the
streets protesting and just like in the
united states and many other places
around the world at some point the
protests run in to the government
but what we do know is that china and
their response to these protests they
have even surprised the protesters
themselves if you boil the situation
down to its first principles there are
people they took their life savings they
put it in the bank and they thought it
was safe but now as they've tried to
withdraw that money the bank isn't
giving it back it's a major problem
obviously for those in china who are
being forced to deal with this but also
if it starts to happen in many other
places around the world bank runs are as
old as time but what we are watching
happen here where people are being
frozen out from their deposits
that causes a lot of fear and
uncertainty and it makes people question
how the entire system works
now i don't know how this situation will
play out and i'm not an expert on
chinese politics or on the chinese
banking system but i do know that the
story is the same for people around the
world
if they take their money and they put it
in banks they always want the ability to
go and get it out
if they are not able to do that the fear
can drive all sorts of concerns and i
think that's exactly what we're watching
play out here in china bitcoin as a
decentralized digital currency it allows
for self-sovereignty anyone in the world
can hold their private keys if you don't
hold your private keys slash your
bitcoin
and the reduction of counterparty risk
the reduction of trust in third parties
that is something that is being ushered
in by the digital age
and bitcoin
as the reserve currency of that digital
age is at the forefront of teaching
people that self-sovereignty is going to
become incredibly important in the years
to come